tamar let's sit down have a proper chat
real quick can we do that yes we can
how are you doing because i'm looking at
you and i see a glow in your eyes see
it's like it's back
oh well listen kevin i really worked
hard at my glow in my eyes you know
it's been a long time that i haven't um
you know put on a mask put on the ritz
as we call it in show business
um and i had to learn how to check in
with myself
and to make sure that i am not giving
so much that i forget about me
i love that um you wrote that you have
now you now have a sober sound
mind and body what does that mean well
you know i mean in order to really um
tune in with yourself it's great to be
sober so you know you don't have
any yeah so you don't have anything that
is like you know
not true i like tangible things these
days right
right you know um so i take time for
myself
i love to work out that's my time with
god that's the time that i am one with
myself
and yeah so i i make sure i pay
attention to you know
my pillars and the things that i need to
make sure i am sound
by the way if you all haven't checked
out under construction tamar's um
podcast it's fabulous you should check
it out
um but under construction means you
and how other people can always you're
always under construction yeah people
can
really fix themselves and build
themselves up well i wanted to
normalize mental health and i also
wanted to
create a platform to heal out loud i
just feel like my ministry now
is to give my struggles
my journey and not be ashamed of it so
the next person
will feel the same way that is really
hard for people though it is hard to
tell the truth and look at yourself and
say
yeah that was crazy well i didn't write
it but the truth shall set you free
and it's more freeing than ever and i
feel more amazing i actually feel like
i'm in my 20s i feel great
do you oh yes hey mark does that mean
love could be on the horizon
love could be on the horizons i i'm i'm
open
you know but i'm not dating right now um
i am actually dating myself yeah and i'm
dating my life
um i want to make sure i spend the time
and to make sure i hit all of my goals
and to make sure i'm the best mother
that i can possibly be and be present
for myself and for him
you mentioned being a great mom logan
how is he doing because i mean i
remember him being here
years ago running around this studio
yeah yeah well you know i actually gave
birth to myself
and that means you know he has a big
personality he's super fun
enlightening um but at the end of the
day i have to make sure that mentally i
check in with him too so we go to
counseling together
absolutely um because you know my my
whole thing is to make sure
his happiness is first and if he doesn't
know how to communicate that
then i'm not doing my job as a parent i
have to show him how to communicate how
he's feeling
in the inside wow so you're doing the
work
you are doing the work hey um how are
you
and your sisters doing how how's the
family doing how's tony doing with her
love life
listen i can't talk about tony braxton's
love life you know i have changed i
am shade free now i went to shade
anonymous oh you went to shade anonymous
and let it go
yes i did um but you know listen tony is
my older sister
she's an amazing woman and you know i i
don't know what i did in my life to be
so lucky to have
such an amazing family an amazing family
full of beautiful amazing
african-american women um and so you
know i i
take a lot of their advice i take a lot
of their experiences and you know i use
it you know for my good
you are i'm doing a lot of singing on
social medias
[Music]
does that mean music is in the works ah
yes music is in the works
what does that mean tamara well that
means well i was in the studio last
night so you never know
what does that mean tamar why why would
you come here and kind of try and play
around
tell me what's going on listen this
coven has tried us all right
yeah yeah yeah and so you know that was
definitely a project that i wanted to
put out you know long before now
but i do feel like there's a lot of
story to tell
and i can't tell that overzoom i want
you to be able to come to the show and
feel me
and be healed and let's stay under
construction together
wow can i play something for you this is
uh yes you know we have we have lots of
moments from our e.t
vault i'm gonna take you back to 1993.
wow yeah here we go
[Music]
she's always in trouble what does she do
today guys thank you so much
she's the youngest everyone's picky
going her yeah but
we have to are we picking on you no
we're so i'm sorry tamara
i'm sorry
and the only explanation i can
find wow
oh wow you were 16 the braxton sister's
doing the carpenter
what do you remember about that time oh
my god i remember my sister tony making
us sing courtney songs
all the time i mean the carpenters are
definitely not corny but at that time
when you're 16
you want to pop block and drop it and i
definitely wasn't doing that
but oh my god my sisters are amazing and
i love them so much
and the great thing about family is that
you can have disagreements
but at the end of the day you always
come back to the core and that's family
what would you tell that 16 year old
girl if you could send her a message
right now
ah well hello 16 year old tamar it is
okay for your struggles for
you to question yourself for you to
challenge yourself
but the only thing that you have is
yourself so
trust in yourself believe in the process
and you'll be okay
wow profound you know
hashtag under construction
i love that hey would you ever go back
to doing any reality tv with your
sisters
unfortunately no um no i just think it
changes our dynamic and i would rather
have
my sister's love and affection off
camera than
to be bickering arguing and fighting on
camera that's just not the example i
want to say
it's hard though for people because it's
it's like an intoxicant
to come and you in the love you get in
the you know
the people talking about you when you're
when you're on tv
yeah you never know you know how success
is going to hit you right
um and for me unfortunately more
negative than
positive you know once you you know go
down the road of success sometimes it
can have a toxic effect
and then that toxic effect can trickle
down on
your everything that you're doing in
your life in your relationships your
relationship with your family your job
all the positive things that you have
going for yourself sometimes it can
definitely negatively affect that
what was when things were at their worst
what was the thing you did
that made it better
um because i think a lot of people they
they hit a rock bottom point
and they can't figure out how do i get
how do i get back
up and start going again well for me i
was definitely there
um i am definitely um someone who knows
what rock bottom looks like
what it feels like and not being able
to pull myself out um because i think as
people
we we do the figuring out oh i can
figure out how to go to work or i can
figure out how to take the kids i can
figure out how to put on a face
but sometimes you're just so dark you're
so
so sunking into that sunken place that
you can't see the light
but i promise you kevin god is the light
and you have to remember that he is
within all of us
so the only thing that can get you out
is your mind you have to think positive
and be positive
and that's just what i did tell me about
your upcoming virtual retreat
what is going to happen oh kevin i'm so
excited about this
yes um it's called lucky 21 and it's
just about um
receiving and entering in your lucky
season
yes i'm claiming that for everyone
because you know after such a dark time
in my life
i feel like i'm living my best life and
this retreat is just about connecting
with like-minded people
who are figuring out um the
tech world the entertainment world um we
have a prayer breakfast i'm excited
about
yeah yeah yeah how does somebody get
involved with this yeah uh well you can
go to my instagram and you can click on
the link in my bio um because i don't
remember
but that's the smart thing go to your
instagram click on the link in my bio
and it will give you
all the information and it's tamar
braxton yeah
all four million of y'all out there yeah
don't miss this this is going to be
amazing
[Music]